for many video game fans there's one
gift that can be counted on to deliver
excitement year after year and that's
the new call of duty game this year's
edition is black ops 3 and if you've got
a call duty fan on your holiday shopping
list we've got a great gift loadout
lined up for you in this episode of our
holiday gift guide in black ops 3 the
soldiers of the future are outfitted
with gadgets and gizmos that are a
little bit beyond what we consumers can
purchase today though we may not be able
to get drones to fly out of our cyber
bodies and light our enemies on fire we
can get drones that fly around our
living room and light the place up with
festive LEDs this mosquito drone from
sharper image flies around speedily and
is a great way to practice your drone
skills without getting in trouble with
the FAA if you prefer your gifts to be a
little more grounded then let's talk
about some mega bloks there are a ton of
Call of Duty mega bloks to capture the
festive charm of everyone's favorite
mode zombies hanging out with shambling
undead is a great time and here they are
doing some of their typical zombie
activities such as hanging out in a
diner escaping from jail cleaning up
hazardous waste and earning an honest
day's work on the farm make these
shambling Horrors a part of your world
today in the fast-paced multiplayer
conflicts of black ops 3 any advantage
can make the difference and that's why
these control freaks accessories could
be a boon to a cod ace on your list the
extra height confers a broader range of
motion which could lead to increased
accuracy and the grippy surfaces help
you stay in control but things get tense
which in call of duty multiplayer is
like all the time this next item is for
those of you who wish the future was
here now well have some good news
totally is the Samsung gear VR is a
headset it uses your Samsung device to
power a range of virtual reality
experiences watch 360 degree videos
including live sports and entertainment
events explore photos that give a whole
new meaning to the word panoramic play
video games and a whole new way with the
Samsung gear VR you can experience the
mind-bending immersion of virtual
reality in the comfort of your own home
without any of the pesky battlefield
hazards or invasive neural implants at
the black ops 3 soldiers have to deal
with
armed with these gift ideas you're ready
to deploy into the holiday shopping
season and use the power of military
puns to accomplish your objective good
luck soldiers I mean shoppers
you